[Music]
foreign
the concerns that it will be kind of a
private militia or it will be parallel
parallel to the existing forces to work
at the same territory with the different
commanding it will be a disaster
[Music]
oh
no
we can't accept that there will be any
kind of law enforcement which is not
under the regulation the law in in order
of the police commissioner
[Music]
I've seen a worsening of the
anti-palestinian
rhetoric and incitement against the
Palestinians that has clearly possibly
impacted
um the violence that has been Unleashed
against the Palestinians I've seen an
increase in the forms of humiliation and
in the indignities that are imposed on
the Palestinians
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign foreign
[Music]
foreign